hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang out every Tuesday 2 p.m.
rewind it was lovely rewind you like
that I liked it pretty happy with it
hello welcome to lobby game Konstanty
hang it every tuesday at two p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com I'm
your host Daniel why I joined as ever by
Andy Bell man I'm his notebook yep every
time whatever there now I can talk as
fast as you cuz I'm drinking bout du Luc
wow it's amazing we should you should
you Jeff kili kili right now yeah every
single will know more now so we're sorry
call tonight though that's where I
weren't a coke shirt and I was it is
that's almost like your absolute satires
mr. yeah destiny note bull like destiny
don't like my page I've got news hey
Justin hey Walt has been good enough to
hide his coffee container I was gonna
bring a bag of Doritos it's it's a
religious water once I say the mighty
ducks note some lightning might be giant
they might be giants it's this bad it's
a you probably have not heard yeah
everyone's got their I think they were
an additional hog game were they we've
been playing a bunch of Tony Hawk this
morning we're gonna talk about that
later add the good things and the bad
things also going to talk about the
witcher 3 expansion pack movies known as
hearts of stone hearts of stone at Yuma
hardly talked about last week that's
right i mean i saw the b-roll that they
sent over yes to use in that video but
you guys actually played it which i
haven't been able to play i mean i'm
excited to play it and they done now and
they didn't show the bureau of what I
played we get weird Grand Theft Auto
style high stuff yes what are gonna get
Sally we've also got a mary kay should
return and justin and everyone returned
from tokyo game show we got a bunch of
stuff to give away from there we're
gonna split it out over a couple of
weeks i just ran over and grabbed some
random things from that bag we're gonna
give away this week so stay tuned to be
in with a chance to win some of that
stuff however there has been an argument
in the office for the past couple of
weeks and randolph ramsey in our weekly
meeting this morning wanted to put an
end to it ok he wanted to know which is
better forza or project cars yeah so you
guys are taking positions on this yes
you see we have kind of strong opinions
on both sides one gets an easy one any
Forza is like a clear winner in this
particular your massive force of fun
get us through I mean I'm a massive
project cars phone I mean I like project
cars a lot cuz the great thing about
parts of cards is it's on PlayStation 4
okay and it's on pc i played on pc yeah
yeah and forts adjust isn't on those
things um and I don't know if I'd have
an xbox if it wasn't for Forza I want to
talk to you okay force it in you first
of all reason why you own the car you
own now it's a little bit because I more
connected to fourth yeah yeah I own a
pretty badass car because of Forza okay
explain i would say that well I've
always wanted a WRX a Subaru and so
forth it just was like yeah you should
get one cuz why not it's awesome and so
I got one with a really absurdly loud
muffler and lowered to the ground that's
badass it makes the worst noises ever
yeah how does it look in the rain okay
so forth okay so driveclub still wins
the rain debate doesn't you want to get
real gritty wit looks better it just
looks cool but forces rain play like the
actual feeling of the car is great I
know at e3 it felt weird because I
played that demo too and I was like this
is way too much but like dude the rain
in in the actual game is really good and
like you feel like you're on the edge of
control the whole time and then you
slide out but then you can actually like
recover really easily using the
controller which brings me to my point
the controller itself this is point one
I guess appropriate if we're going you
know I cabal this directly to project a
project so using an xbox one controller
the game feels incredible even compared
to five and I was thinking it was like
in my own head I think enough people
have like agreed and confirmed that like
the tweaks they made to just make it
feel great the driving the way you can
cry like overcorrect and then like bring
it back and all with the thumbstick just
is incredible and there isn't you can
you can tweak the hell out of the
controls and project cars and you pretty
much have to to even get it to feel good
at all like it the default settings even
on the xbox one version of the game are
just awful for playing on a controller
you have to like tweak all day and they
give it and like props to them they give
you everything you could tweak
everything that game which is cool as
hell and you can get all the settings
and you bracket it all in and get it all
dialed and then it's like yeah it still
feels okay see it's weird right because
I can't even argue
that point because I play this game yeah
your wheel and pedals which is the way I
love to play racing games yeah that
better feed bag like that is like racing
a car do you even have that option with
something like 14 you do yeah of course
I just have never done it because I just
prefer the gamepad I think it's for is
the only driving game I've ever played
where I actually felt like the gamepad
did a like I felt comfortable yeah
really driving with the game grab
because like I play all the old f1 games
and stuff I like playing those games
with a pad just doesn't for the type of
driving you do and that sort of stuff it
doesn't work and that's why I love on
driveclub like the amount of different
disciplines that are in there and the
different types of handling required
like I'll be driving like a Formula a
car which is there sort of formula one
take and I have a project car sorry
project car project cars and what the
message i close yeah so sorry and that
all the go-kart stuff for that darling
library it's incredible that feels
totally right there like they're at
formula B cars there like all the
supercars everything feels completely
different the feedback is different the
grip is different like I remember the
first time I tried to drive a Formula a
car I went up through for me to see for
him to be and I got two formulae and I
was trying to like start on the line my
first race in Monza and I like going to
first gear and the car just goes nope
because I've got my foot to the pedal
and pedal to the metal and it just goes
you have to like teach yourself how each
one of these cars feels with the
steering wheel feedback and I think it's
like that's I've been enjoying project
cars so much because and it's the thing
I think that surprises me is project
cars is a racing name that doesn't have
a rewind function yeah so you have to be
really good so I love the rewind
function because like you know you're
playing a game I'm I don't care do you
like so yeah the recoil Asian reports it
lets you once you mess up a little bit
you're able to go back in time a few
seconds and make better choices you
better drive yeah cuz like you go into a
turn and you want to be like our I'm
going too late apics this and like this
and see if that works out and then like
your abs doesn't really catch and you
just slide all and you blow the turn
your like I owe everyone but it's like I
couldn't like play around with that sort
of stuff in project cars I felt like
although it is that is an experience to
be like completely concentrating so much
in project cars are like
turn turn turn but I was playing really
conservative and like I don't know we
have this footage I'm like yeah it's
pretty this game is pretty good actually
it looks gorgeous do ya like the helmet
cam and stuff too in the cars I really
like I cuz it gives you the depth of
field like gives you the view of the
inside of the helmet whereas like Forza
doesn't really do that yeah like I not
many driving games do that where you
actually see the helmet on your head in
fact Chris and the guys and GameSpot UK
did oculus rift on it and apparently
it's just insane because we've just got
your guy your eyes here like this you
can kind of barely hear the engine as
well it's kind of muffled a little bit
so you really feel like you're like
stuck inside of the engine I think it
shouldn't run to the wheel I think
that's a good I think project cars does
have like this edge when it comes to
things like that like the fact that
you're gonna put VR on if you want to
it's like there's customization is just
insane the different disciplines are all
like it's it's like pretty good yeah i
guess that y intercepts got a lot going
yeah and it's all like dialing dial and
like you want to do a race weekend it's
like you can qualify you can you know
get your place in the starting grid you
can decide i'm a rock fuel you can
practice it's like you can if you want
you can do like a formula formula we can
I 24 hour thing yeah or you can do like
an f1 race with like 60 cards how much
just to see laughing yet so it's like Oh
crash it's cool but like and I think
that kind of gives it like this edge
yeah Oh for me as a casual player
someone who is definitely much more
comfortable with Mario Kart than it's
really hardcore games project cars looks
amazing like I love looking at
screenshots of this game like it's right
so realistic looking and I think that
stands out for just a lot of players
that you're able to get more out of a pc
than you are out of any console and it's
gonna look amazing yeah and it certainly
does stand out but here's but like
saying that I think Forza is just like
it's the newest version force of six the
cars all look just great and the
difference is here's an example in this
clip I'm driving an Alfa Romeo 4c and
this new track is amazing too it looks
really great so in Brazil is yeah or
that and that's like I don't think alfa
romeos are even in project cars and
think the new nissan idx cool track toys
in project cars like mice to peruse
aren't in project cars yeah I could go
on and on and on and formula ears is in
Forza yeah and in project cars it's all
fake unlicensed formula a it's like a
made-up thing basically it's f1 yeah so
like yeah you're right even even does
lotuses I don't think with Lamborghinis
in yeah project and that matters to you
right a little bit because I'm cut cuz i
come by at it from like I like Top Gear
I like them doing weird stuff with
really cool cars and and they or just
the films they make about testing the
cars car passion car passion importances
got that [ __ ] down here so well and it's
never been better because not only are
you taking these cars out in the rain at
night if they feel better they control
better on the X bar they control great
on that's what there's just so many of
them it's so comprehensive there's so
many tracked now 425 that was a problem
there was like no [ __ ] try yeah
that's er um then six that give you
money like they just give you millions
and millions of course sorry about
sports a five yeah they're like member
how you had to work really hard for your
Subaru BRZ sorry about that now you can
buy like a million-dollar car from the
first like wheel spin or whatever so
yeah like I don't know four to six just
seems to be like this comprehensive
package of serious car [ __ ] like the
tracks the cars the way it controls its
all there and it's all ready to go and
it's like yeah you can't do a race
weekend where your qualifying you know
running out your pit crew and your gas
and yeah all that gets your point across
not likes yeah it's so intricate this is
just like now I get top three in this
race and if you don't restart try again
it's like Andy feels the way about four
to six as I do about project cars it's
just like a something about an econo
comms answer the pro f versus FIFA thing
we had last week where there's a certain
elements of like different strokes for
different folks and it comes to car
games like have something feels it's
such like a really difficult thing to
nail down like why one game feels better
than another okay so these are a lot of
big points if you were who is this game
for like it sounds like they're almost
four different people and so maybe and
so who is a person who sports project
cars to gain from here for gamers well
no brother well by default
magic cards again that was developed by
racing [ __ ] game fans it's like a
community as I can online shared like
they're based in London some of the team
and but like that was built by a group
of people who just love card games and
wanted to make a card game for
themselves forces obviously the opposite
end this is massive triple-a thing
they've got the licenses but it's also
made by people who care about game yeah
cars so I guess it's like one of them is
made for me one of them is made for the
console cried one of those made for the
pc cried i'm one of those more hardcore
and another one is just a bit more I
guess polished around it I'd say because
driveclub certainly is like as it's like
peaks and valleys yeah I don't know
about dry right pressure course project
cars you can do some giant claw I don't
like Troy hahaha god dammit that may
confuse video I mentioned to hear what
people in the comments think though
you're so yeah yo your project your I
love forsa like I didn't think I was
gonna like force 26 right because I was
like well it's just few more cars and
tracks like whatever but like I don't
know they've just done enough that it's
great it's so good and like project cars
I loved playing it in the summer because
it was like and yeah force a game right
now although I was still playing horizon
2 which is the best sports game ever me
Amy yeah probably i like parts of cars
but i never felt comfortable i was
always like I was he's like I was always
felt like as in crashed car and then I
probably cause you any way I was cuz i
do and i hit restart like with forza
even a few mess of a turf blow thing
it's like II rewind and then you watch
the replay and it's all seamless that's
like you didn't do anything wrong even
where you drifted your way to success
all right you're still in the fourth
camp hell I'm still on the project cars
camp I mentioned here and why you guys
think in the chato let us know are you a
actually are you a drunk fine yeah just
agree with us completely I do you like
project cars you like forts are you
waiting for Gran Turismo let us know in
the comments below and we've got a bunch
more stuff to talk about it today Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater five is that we're
gonna talk about the witcher 3 with mr.
my hardy in a little bit you to stay
around Tony Hawk something x but first
of all here's the trailer for a persona
for dance the night away dancing
have you heard that rumor there's this
weird video that plays on its own when
you watch the video to the end you could
take it away to the other side and you
never wake disappeared economy and
kitchen girls if we can face people i'm
all for it I think it's definitely
better than doing nothing this
definitely give a bit easier could you
help me out I want to save them you tell
me leave it to me all right here goes
let the music play all right let's start
very very bad we'll show you great items
unbeatable prices must brace ourselves
there's no knowing what to expect
investigation team let's move persona 4
dancing all night it's been 16 years
since the first Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
came out what they finally got around to
making a fifth one and he suddenly feels
very old Oh six layers and I'll go wrong
16 years we're still talking about video
games 1999 man crazy night at Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 5 is it today by no
means the 5th Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
game we played a bunch for this morning
it's come out its controversial yeah
let's let's break it down and okay
Justin you haven't played any won't be
the first question you have that mean
onto your plate of the bunch what I've
played it a little bit umm so so why is
this the game that's coming back after
oh I think people really gravitated
towards skate Vittorio due to a very
different style of controlling like Tony
how it feels like a throwback throwback
in a lot of ways is is this a kind of
experience that you guys wanted after
how well-received skate was I'm a
massive fan of Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
I'm a huge fan of the skate series i
think skate series is probably like top
five best sports games of all time in
probably in there what would honk a
little bit and i think it's just a
matter of that game was very much
catering to the skateboarding crowd like
that was to people who like care about
like nailing you know shove it over a
three stare as opposed to tongue hawk
which is kind of this like skate culture
melange of like music and and like
popular skaters and interesting maps and
sort of you know crazy modes and
objectives so to me it's like Oh
Activision had this thing this is the
right time to bring it back this in
guitar hero why not yeah what I'm kind
of surprised the bed is that this is a
sixty-dollar game because that game tony
hawk's one or two or three incredible
games that game released nowadays isn't
this type of experience that you because
it's very repeatable so it doesn't feel
like the type of game you'd spend 60
on that would be charged love especially
in 2015 when you got games are charged
99 cents the whole way up to fifty
dollars and everything in between or 60
and everything in between so that's the
way in which i think this game feels a
little weird does this feel like a 60
dog into you so far on d know and i know
that the HD remake wasn't yes yannick
kind of feels that caliber although it
like seems to work a little bit better
like overall but i was actually thinking
like it when i was doing okay so first
point when i played Tony Hawk 5 for the
first time it was like a couple weeks
ago yeah we were doing a little demo and
I didn't have it I was like what
happened I'm not and I kind of blamed
the game yes doesn't feel like Tony
Hawk's doesn't feel like it and then
last week we were working on our big
thing about Tony Hawk and we played a
bunch and we played on ps3 the original
game with the like backwards
compatibility and that the same thing
happened I was like oh this is 15 years
later my brain has changed my hands are
changed like I can't do this [ __ ] so I
was like okay so it's not the game it's
me I just suck really bad so have you
gotten used to it ago but now I've
gotten back and do it after playing a
lot from the original games and then
this morning we're playing a lot and
like I'm not nearly as good as you
because you had a lot of like practice
with your games and you were like
slaying those down and then you're
slaying this down and it's like okay I
started picking this backup started
feeling it and it feels it's like oh
yeah this feels good yeah so definitely
the main in orange I think that they've
done is that now when you hit the grind
button it basically slams you yeah and
we were like maybe that's bad but you
can correct yourself off of vert ramps
where you go off and it's like you're
gonna land flat yeah and then you like
it kind of reorients you in / which is a
nice little feature but it definitely
changes the flow so like if you're like
jumbled words before you'd hit triangle
to basically cue up a grind so you do it
click you do a jump and your bed to hit
one you'd hit triangle then by the time
you hit it it like a new you hit
triangle yeah where's now if you do it
it basically almost like snowboarding
style you like you pressure down to like
sort of like it's slicing back yet okay
so that changes up the game a bit and
and then I'd sided out this kind of I
guess let's break this day this is a
game where you sort of it's kind of more
in the realm of tony hawk's 3 where
you've got as much time as you want in
these areas and you basically go up to
objective markers that are litter around
the map and then there are things like
okay here's a part where Tony's going to
share moves at you and you have to do
the tricks or here's a bit where you
have to like do as many manuals as you
can in two minutes or you know get as
many vert scores as you want and in the
first level here in the barracks which
is Reynolds's real skatepark down in MLA
and you know that's like okay like these
are like tutorial II kind of objectives
that they're trying to teach me except
then I went to the next level and I was
almost the same objectives just in a
different place like there was one here
when you're in this pool or sorry in the
in the barracks where it's like they
fill the pool for the balls yeah big
inflatable balls and you have to get
used to like skate into them and get rid
of them and get them on it and it's kind
of fun it's like a neat little diversion
except that I went in school three which
is like the new version of school too
and here's a pool inside and they're
like can't let the balls are now sports
balls from school but you still have to
get rid of them so like now I'm a little
bit worried that there's like that much
repetition yeah and I avoided they like
objective based stuff when I was just we
skate I was just free skating I found
that to be good and I was like oh this
is toned down as far as like the crate
like you don't spin as fast like I
wasn't even in sevens you can really
like be double dream kicks website or
either yeah I kind of like the boiling
how to go do the little bells this is a
small skate like like some sort of
hybrid oh right like go a little easier
and like really plan out your in roots
and like yeah if you plan on your roots
will be rewarded really well I'm like
it'll be awesome but then I like hit
these ramps in school too yeah just like
arbitrarily wanjiku oh yeah and then I
was spitting sevens no problem and then
like when you hit the special you do
like a multiple you can like it just
basically turns all your tricks and the
specials yeah kind of cool which is
weird but then those are like more
fantastical we're like it's not skating
yeah right back to you do a kickflip in
it that he does a Christ air because
you're in like special mode hey this is
cool is it yeah is that fun yes
difference I just was I just wasn't sure
where the where it was on the spectrum
and now like yeah it's more Tony Hawk
yeah still Tony Hawk it's just you gotta
like find those spots that launch you to
in order I still haven't spun nine like
it does feel though I was talking to
jeff gerstmann from giant bomb right
before we came on
m and he was saying that they're getting
reports they know that big patch that
arrives the first like day one patch is
like as big as the game whatever like I
made seven gigs panty that has most of
the game in it and it kind of does feel
like a game whose finished about a week
ago because like the UI stuff is super
weird like for instance if you go up to
an objective marker you have to stop
right beside it like knowing you can't
get off the board if the stubborn and
then hold down x it's not like Burnett
where you could like go in the realm of
it and then hold X and it'll start just
go right there and then when you do that
for some reason like the menu swaps from
the analog stick to the d-pad you're
like okay and it's the weird stuff like
when you start objectives sometimes I
don't clue what I'm doing the first time
I kind of have to figure it out for
myself like is one right to like Tiki
lamps didn't we tell me anything about
where they were and then I was like no
you can't you're outside the objective
or you go back here so it seems very
rough around the edges now well the
thing that's getting the most attention
right now are people having horrible
glitches that's what's getting shared
around on the idea sorry is it is that
what you guys been experiencing not at
all no I think we've seen one in the
past two hours but then we've only been
doing so we haven't played online and
we've also not been doing the maybe like
two big one and we're not be giving the
like we've been graded creative wait
yeah park so all the created levels
apparently that's where that that's
where the so does your video edge where
people are going through the floor and
all that sort of stuff but I haven't
seen that happen in the three levels
that we platinum a so it doesn't seem
like a total hot mess that the
Internet's making it out no no no but
it's also $60 mess it's like whatever
this is like Peters reviewing it first
this is real like midler road I'm
enjoying it because it's like a big
nostalgic yeah I'm genuinely enjoying
this and will genuinely probably try and
like one hundred percent this game like
really kind of like I mean I'm just like
whatever you skating I don't know if
I'll ever do the missions man hey I mean
you have to unlock the levels though so
I got it will however to do that in
witness America it's weird though
because they have things like create a
skater mode or there's no like sloth for
you to create somebody you just have to
edit an existing skater which seems
weird it's just super lice and just let
it end your rental yeah Andrew balance
like I don't really like Nyjah Huston i
guess i'll just change i'm about the
same height as him let's just do that
yolo county yeah it's it's weird it's
it's like I feel like I'm enjoying it
mostly
the fact that I'm a big Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater fine and also because i think i
came in with this with such low
expectations that I'm actually kind of
pleasantly surprised that it's it's kind
of all right so maybe not the best
introduction though for people who don't
have that nostalgia hit who didn't grow
up with Tony Hawk no no as I can't I
don't even know what who that is yeah
like I you know what I grow my skate or
die okay yeah hell yeah I have that make
you feel a little bit younger no it
makes me just feel older that's like
older older older older so if I played
skater guy it's yet so it so I'm very
into two reviews for this game or cuz I
can see it like sliding completely non
op sedans and it's kind of like we're
talking about the car games earlier so
much of it goes dancer what he was
saying at the stars like does this feel
right yeah just feel like I'm in control
of what I'm usually blamed the game for
being terrible damn i just went over
that dinner I can he was like this does
not feel like it Tony all came to me
yeah but see he's remembering long I bet
it doesn't happen to me I was like when
you go back and play Resident Evil
you're like oh man this is like
impossible to control and I totally
forgot that games you or like the
original tomb raider the version you
have in your head of heavy original tomb
raider plate is like totally different
to to the reality of it so i wonder if
the game looks very Arkady and that's
kind of what i remember is tony hawk
being of the an arcade eversion this
kind of game and feels like it's gonna
live up to that yeah i just worry that i
I really don't think it's a sixty-dollar
game like is it gonna be better than
tony hawk ride when you had that yes
controller there was the martha was thus
keyboard i can confirm right now that it
is better than tony hawk ride and the
thread shred was a lot huh yeah i think
that had snowboarding it ends 00 tight
yeah there's a snowboarding level in it
well there's a mad no level yeah so
we'll see I think we have to got a lot
some more and unlock them all and see
you had a restful place but yeah early
adopters is really does not feel like a
sixty-dollar proposition but I guess
we'll find out what gamespot com thinks
we assume Peter banners reviewing Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater five and that review
will be up sometime this week these are
more plain to do because we didn't get
an early copy as well which is always a
little bit of a concern but if you've
played us or seen people play it or a
big fan of series or looking to get into
it let us know what you think in the
chat and in the comment box below
alright we've got one more section to
talk about I've got some went cards
you're really wild we really will get a
life get games to life instead life's to
gain weight well hey disney infinity
watch your back yeah but before that
actually we're gonna give away a little
swag bag at which Mary Kish brought back
gentlemen do you want to have an item
each from the swag bag yeah little right
so we got us so much stuff may be
brought back so much stuff like over 100
bucks where the stuff from Japan so
we're gonna do this we're gonna divvy
this out in a bunch of different ways
and the gamespot Twitter account and at
gamespot is gonna be tweeting at the end
of the show to make sure you follow
acting spot and a retweet for a chance
to win this is for north america only
and the items were giving away this week
are Justin hey Walt we got a Kirby from
hoshino kavi is what it says on the
thing it's just a you know generic Kirby
from the Nintendo franchises super cute
smiling he's not the angry eyes Korea we
get in the states to had the ice cream
yeah cuz he's back in his native land
although now we have stolen him from his
native land yeah you think you would
have gotten angry on the way here with
man Andy bad one when you got mystery
box for a mug some sort of mom with
Final Fantasy characters this one I
think was specifically from final
fantasy 14 aight so you have some
googles and I feel chocobo there's
chocobo a whole bunch of enemies from
the from the game much nature cat my
favorite part is that along the bottom
it says 2010-2013 square enix all rights
reserved final fantasy oh the bobbin 15
maybe it's a final fantasy square enix
there you go and last but certainly not
least God curry of the biohazard yeah
biohazard of course the title for
resident evil in Japan and increase
green it's actually green it's gray and
I wish you could be here with me too
like it's like in there it's like a
plaque gooey it's like a gue situation
yeah you can heat it up in hot water and
then just eat it straight out of the
pack green herb healing curry so combine
two of these together three times as
much I'd love to read the ingredients to
you but they're all in some sort of
weird language I always pickin read day
you know Japanese well it's gonna be
made with onions spinach say that wait
are you making it up
are you know tominaga Lorenzo torrini
koo sow chicken coconut Sammy Dooku
coconut milk powder it's a like there's
also like the words in Japanese that are
just kind of loanwords okay so it
literally says in a phonetic alphabet
coconuts coconuts amid uu KU Powell dot
alright that's cool egyptian i can speak
japanese better like a lot green curry
paste important basil basil paste sugar
fish flakes like I said Basel not basil
chicken eggs I was gonna write chicken
extract which is ever green earth were
you ever a situation in tgs and Japan
when you're speaking Japanese saved your
life I might have died if I wasn't able
to speak Japanese they yeah they're very
strict there did you ever get out of a
sticky situation why not sure it's notes
helpful it's helpful to speak Japanese
but everyone there so so nice like Jay
Japan is just incredibly polite and just
will bend over backwards to help you do
things and especially when you're in
Tokyo when you're an old sock I like
people speak English if you don't know
what's going on that one okay hold
weight and they'll find someone who
speaks English better than they do you
live that in the countryside like yeah
when you lived there you were acting
nowhere near a major middle of nowhere
Okinawa yeah so I had to learn I had to
learn to survive like that was how I
went to the grocery store like what what
can i eat what is here is food please
help me haha cuz otherwise like I'm
porno so i can i can just eat this like
that i'm stupid so it's just gone up in
value in it it just because i licked it
a little curry of the biohazard sweet
final fantasy cup and a kirby can be all
yours and make sure you follow gamespot
on the Twitter RT that bad boy and cross
your fingers for a chance to win all
that sweet sweet swag sweet sweet where
it is I like the box the cup comes in
the most that's great awesome stay tuned
be back in a second my priorities in the
wings and we're going to talk about the
witcher 3 and play some quaint so stay
tuned we back in just a second you're 80
GS 2015 and i am here to get you guys
some awesome swag at all the different
merch booth sui
here there's a lot of sweet stuff there
is a huge com booth and of course Square
Enix always has not just regular
products you can buy but amazing display
cases filled with goodies so I'm going
to walk around and see what kind of cool
stuff I can get
to go through here but all this stuff
can be yours I'm going to be giving away
on the lobby so be sure to stay tuned to
the lobby on gamespot and check it out
and find out how you can win all this
awesome stuff I wanted to get all home
with me but I can't so thank you guys so
much for watching and stay tuned you can
win some was awesome stuff dude I got
gerelds of rivia in this pack I got
Gerald of rivia right there look at him
I got ghoul I got Griffin Griffin got
five attack Mike what about your pack
your pain with the monster pack oh so I
got the bad guys sweet yeah down full
pack you don't do that over first look
how many vendors I went to in special
quests I did Dennis Cranmer don't recall
meeting him throughout the witcher 3 but
Dennis Cranmer he looks I think he's a
dwarf I got seems like a lot easier than
in game where you have to get that
collect needs one by one clear whether I
did not clear whether sword fight but
goblin for these how much Quentin you
play in The Witcher 3 the bare minimum
oh yeah it was good great i just i'd
rather be killing ghouls and stuff
really yeah then collecting a sick fiend
from a ha c'mon feet or maja c'mon this
is the this is the the boxed copy of The
Witcher threes and expansion pack hearts
of stone which I love because you
literally open up the box and then
inside is a download code for the game I
was going to say so the expansion pack
is not actually a game it's no the card
card game that that's the new expansion
bag yeah yep there's a piece of card
here with the code on it which I can't
show you folks and then you basically
have a thing that has a bunch of
Quentin's to full packs it's got the i
guess the monster set and i forget the
name of what you call this the main set
whatever it's called starter deck yeah
whatever I forgetting a torrential rain
torrential rain but apparently in the
Northern Kingdom Spears fall when it
rains as well yes got to be careful
Cloudy with it look at these names I
love this look at all this like stuff
for like Gwen's it's like so confident
my favorite
they give you two packs because if they
gave you one you'd have to find someone
else who also bought the Bucks expansion
bike and you can easily divvy these up
into like two people like you could chop
this pack and half easy and still have
an absolutely massive set and it'll end
even though this is like a physical
version that you can play they've said
before that they don't want to turn this
into its own game yeah mostly because
like some of these rare cards make your
deck kind of Opie yeah I know Garrett of
Rivia has like something stupid like 16
so like that's like that's that's that's
ridiculous EOP we're not here to talk
about real-world grentz there's more to
this expansion his wins there is the
expansion also comes with a video game
and we played a bunch of hearty stone
last week hearthstone hearts no not
hearthstone not hearthstone on anything
hearts of stone heart of startups I know
look I know it's a card game and it says
hearts and stone on it but it's not hard
though hearts of stone in their
expansion magic gathering yes much
another go gathering of the magics oh
god dammit yeah they probably should
have thought about actually but we
played some hard to stone last week yeah
we pay for me to three hours yeah and
what was interesting was we sort of
split during our time doing it at before
I talk about the weird stuff that I saw
that there we have no be rolled off and
tell me about your experience what do
you think of hearts of stone I liked it
a lot actually but we played about yeah
like you said 23 hours of about what's
ten our total expansion they said but
again it's a big world so you'll
probably be wandering off the beaten
path once in a while but basically you
just initiate it by going to a bulletin
board where they have this Witcher
contract for like to hunt a beast down
and you keep hearing about it and you
end up going to the sewers as you could
see here and you know Carol being
himself is ready for to kill something
and so was I and in fact what I liked
about this boss fight on a there was a
couple more right off the bottle I felt
like I think I did three in the first
two hours yeah and they were all
interesting and I played this one on
hard mode and barely figured it out and
after the sort of that it's a massive
well let's not say it for this boy is
actually it's a cool boss it definitely
you have to fight it differently than
you might just like a regular
it's it's not it doesn't fall into those
categories of the old ones did just like
a ghoul or a drowner or flying beasts
thing yeah this is totally knew it was
it was tough actually I died once mmm I
think I played on the normal difficulty
yeah I mean I just about did it I did it
on hard and I just and I did it does
this pick up after the main games finish
there is this some kind of in between so
this picks up you have to be is at level
30 yeah recommended around the record I
most of the bosses why was for most of
the enemies I was fighting were like 30
to 33 and by the time i was finna it
sound coop doors 34 35 a couple of hours
into it and so it's that you can go into
it at any stage but you'll never be able
to complete that early mission unless
you're that's like almost like the like
difficulty gates they have and in fact
later on i had story stuff happen which
definitely happened later in the game
referred to so it's like built into it
basically so you need to be ran 30 or so
and like in the last third of the game
for instance so this is also the part i
did ok you saw this part no just like
the ghost thing yeah so old your von
ever at keys the guy who originally
gives you the quest he says he gives you
like these two seemingly mundane
objectives yes you did one I did the
other your sounded way cooler although
mine was pretty entertaining it's like
the crux of this is that you have to
compete a certain for some reason if to
complete a list of things for this guy
and what's pretty cool about is they all
sound like boring fetch quest it's like
take yes my brother out for a night on
the town you're like seriously like you
he could just as easily go to a tavern
by himself yank alone but as it turns
out that's a little more complicated
again I don't it's very story heavy so
I'm gonna spoil it yeah but trust me
it's it's a lot more entertaining that
it's very well set up actually and then
you did one as well yeah I did one which
again I don't want to get into the
nitty-gritty of it because it was
certainly fun to find out but it
basically the mission that I took on was
essentially a heist from Grand Theft
Auto 5 where I needed to get inside of a
building and I was sent on a bunch of
missions to get the crew to do so so
there was a note there was a way to get
into this building but I needed to have
like you know the explosive expert and
it gave me like details on these two
rich characters which I could one of
I could pick up again I also needed to
have like I saw that an infiltration
expert and there was like this cool
gymnast other person just like troll or
dwarf or something like it also am
higher so like immediately went okay
this is all you have to do go out and
find these people and in the limited
time we had I went and find two of them
and to try and like see what they were
like and then they have these very
interesting like unique moments happen
to them so were you playing with them
like did they like play along with you
and you got to see how their abilities
kind of would help you in battle or in
the culmination of this heist yeah you
had to kind of convince them to come
with you and some of them were you know
we're having their own problems and
maybe you need to help or like I had one
who was freaking out because he had a
domestic problem at home let us say and
then I think you could probably talk
about of us but I bet living crap out of
him stats and he decided to work for me
so like it felt like a really clever
setup and also there was earlier in it
there was a part where I was basically
in an auction and because I was a I had
a I guess an account that said their
projects had given to us which had lots
of money I was i basically outbid
everyone but like there was all these
interesting unique dialogue things that
happened during the auction that could
let you know information about the stuff
that was on operand you weren't even
there for the oxygen reader for
committee different reason but it was
like it's just everything about what I
played over the first a couple of hours
of this felt rich felt like really
interesting boss fights really unique
situations I didn't see during my time
time Wild Hunt and I really like the
setup of the main quest with with that
antagonist as well yeah Von Erich geared
yeah essentially a Carter yeah he was we
can't talk about so much oh my god it's
so good we only played like a fifth of
this expansion yeah I initially we had
talked on the lobby a week or two ago
about when we're gonna get into this and
I originally said maybe like early next
year they put into the next expansion
but now that I played it I it's
definitely on my list of things I want
to play among like you know those big
triple I games coming out this fall
because essentially what you did was
like Gerald's 11 or like it was like it
was like a the height this fantasy
setting I kind of went to a wedding and
it was like a sitcom but both seen my
was entertaining as well men now I
really just want to see the heist and
then there's that other question neither
of us really went too far into that yeah
there's more stuff I also did a sigh
quest that was optional that was in this
expansion pack which was pretty
interesting as well yeah yeah this girl
kept calling me Puss peepers probably
because I cats eyes or whatever chic
have called me post beats or papers and
girls was not happy with it and that was
really cool and then there's a bunch of
other stuff as well there's new
abilities a lot of which we did in luck
because they kind of gave us all the
points but we just sort of hurriedly put
them all in and and there's a couple of
new special magic abilities new items as
well quite a lot in there we met Shawnee
for the first time yes three yeah core
character which I guess fans of the
series will remember and she seems very
interesting I liked your explanation on
the video she's kind of smarter than
gerelds yeah I like very much so and
like it's kind of she has a humility
tourist so she kind of talks d'Anjou but
not in there like a love that she's not
looking down I'm she's trying to like
ease him through it which is kind of
it's an interesting dynamic I think yeah
the dialogue is awesome especially
because the brother of Von Erich that
you bring out for the night she joins
you at certainly so it's just her
brother being really crass and gruden
like just like kind of like hitting on
her the entire time and gerelds kind of
like all right just chill out stop being
a jerk and then but she just the whole
time doesn't even give him the time of
day she doesn't care just ignores it but
yeah you sense that gerelds kind of
picking up on the fact that he's way
outpaced by her in terms of intelligence
so she kind of takes it easy on him in
terms of verbal back and forth which is
kind of funny to see him not the boss of
the conversation yeah I'm definitely
gonna jump in earlier to this as well I
think based on I'm playing that I'm
powering through my girl to the moment I
Justin you played a little bit of the
witcher 3 you play like to tell you i
got about 10 15 hours through it i think
it's interesting you guys mentioned like
it's gonna be such a busy holiday yeah
but you're still drawn into this world
like there's both enough content and
that it's interesting enough that you
want to go back into the witcher 3 and
I'm like oh I'm still have to finish the
witcher 3 this is going to be a busy of
the year because we also have a lot of
big RPGs yep fallout 4 like fallout 4 on
itself like that's just an intimidating
thing to think about big time at sash
october 13th so not too far to wait
around that's sort of 25 book
mark depending if you're buying an
online or at retail yeah so let us know
what you think are you going to pick it
up are you gonna pick up this hot
physical heart stone is there a special
edition or is that every edition of the
game and well you can buy digitally and
it doesn't have this oh so but if you
buy this so I imagine it's probably cost
a little bit more but you had no disc
included it says right on the bottom
writing the top pc download only
contains hearts of stone download code
to Gwent cards 154 cards in total I with
game tokens so yeah you're essentially
just reordered buying this what's his
hey reordain sure some elf Reardon is it
rarden may that's an Irish name come on
you should know that feeling like Marty
my middle names Irish Gaelic is what is
it Rouen raw true are you a any Ruane
ruina Americans say oh there's those
Americans dastardly omeros oh yes
American for more weird at gaelic
surnames check out witcher 3 wild hearts
of stone coming like i said october 13
and i let us know if you're gonna pick
it up let's know it's gonna pick up the
weird get Gwen to person let us know if
you're gonna play gwent with your
friends in the comments below all right
John thank you very much for coming on
today Michael he got it on for the rest
of the week what about thought you
couldn't talk about self last week cuz
was under embargo my stuff Irish
uncharted the nathan drake collection
review goes up at 7am tomorrow okay
pacific time and then i'll be playing a
lot of civilization beyond Earth's
rising tide expansions the embargo for
that review sometime next week looking
forward to the same which ticket osh
yeah cuz i guess civil as a gander
through sort of criticized for being a
little bit pedestrian didn't reach shake
the boat up much but sure you know no
point in time is rising tide seems to be
like doing that it was good yeah they're
trying to flush out the middle turns as
opposed just the beginning and end yeah
so it's trying to make it more exciting
throughout i guess yeah so we'll see how
that stays at shipshape next week matey
I just Justin what you think so October
I I can't reveal some of the things that
I might know I'm gonna be coming up but
October is gonna be exciting for more
than just Halloween the middle of the
month if if you guys can remember maybe
an anniversary of something that's going
to be kind of important to us in geek
culture okay there's going to be some
exciting stuff and I'm really excited to
see
how big this gets god damn I can't give
too many hints but it's it's gonna be
really someone cast can figure that went
after me please put it in the comment
box below Tony Hawk yeah Tony Hawk he's
bad I'm gonna go pay so much Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater five see if the objectives
are repeated threat of next five levels
as well and apart from not XCOM 2 we've
got a bunch of features going up and
next week about that we talked to Jake
Salomon at PAX Prime and yeah they've
course fee rox icon is on this weekend
we've got an exclusive streaming on
gamespot com Josh Sean Eric Tara can be
heading out there over to Baltimore at
the stream all that stuff so make sure
you check at the site over the course of
the weekend as well to see Sid Meier &
Co talking mess about all their sweet
games thank you very much guys coming on
the set today appreciate it I will see
you guys next week thanks day one in the
back of course tomahawk Josh Shaw Eric
teh Marrakech although she came back
from Japan is now gone off doing other
crazy things is everything under Margo
they're doing I think it is gonna be
month of coverage of dating this thing
is gonna spread out its go get big thing
on done games well follow me on Twitter
to make sure you catch up on that and of
course gamespot's Twitter account if you
want to win all the cup and zombie on
the kirby and all that stuff make sure
you follow and retweet if you're in
north america for chance to win that I
thanks very much for watching we'll be
back next time of course 2 p.m. pacific
on tuesday right here on gamespot com
and take care of enjoy your games of a
see you next week
you